من اول ما بدات كورونا واحنا بنغطي معكم
خسائر العالم الناجمه عن الجارحه وقطاع
الطيران كان واحد من اكثر القطاعات اللي
بالفعل الضرارات ان لم يكن ربما اكثر
اكثرها لكن اليوم الاتحاد الدولي للنقل
الجوي اياطه اعلن ان الوضع عم يتغير الحمد
لله واخيرا ومن السنه الجاي قطاع الطيران
راح يعود للربحيه ولاول مره من عام 2019
يعني وكانه بالعربي الفصيح بنقول انه قطاع
الطيران تعافى واخيرا من كورونا هذا
القطاع اللي تدمر حقيقه يعني طيران حول
العالم توقف لمده شهور ولا في الرحلات او
الاف الرحلات تم الغائها وتغيرات جذريه
كمان تم ادخالها في اجراءات السفر هذا غير
الخسائر اللي اجبرت شركات الطيران كثير
انها تقيل موظفين يعني معاناه بالفعل
حقيقي هذا كله كان سبب في نقص في التذاكر
مؤخرا واسعار زياده او عاليه جدا وبشكل
غير طبيعي حتى انه السياحه طلع فيها ظاهره
ها السياحه الانتقاميه وهي هبت الناس
للسفر بعض كورونا واللي كنا ربما عشناها
واللي خلت اسعار التذاكر الطيران بتطلع
وتصير غاليه جدا وفي وقت الاتحاد الدولي
بيقول الشركات هترجع تربح في طيارين
معترضين وبيقولوا لا الشركات يا دوب بدات
تتنفس شويه في الارباح في 2019 تجاوزت 26
مليار لكن الان الاتحاد الدولي بتوقع
ارباح ما بتجاوز الخمس مليارات في عام
2023 لكن سؤال الابراج اللي بدنا نطرحه
اليوم همم كل هذا كيف راح ياثر علينا احنا
كمسافرين طبعا رح نناقش هذا الموضوع مع
ضيفنا من القاهره الكابتن محمود القط
الطيار وخبير السلامه الجويه اهلا بك
كابتن معنا همم كابتن احنا كيف راح نتاثر
هل هذا ايش راح يكون منيح لانه نتوقع بما
انه في طلب كثير الاسعار لسه راح تزداد
اكثر وراح نسافر لانه راح تصير غالي كثير
مساء الخير على حضرتك وعلى في الساده
المشاهدين يعني خلينا نشوف الموضوع بنظره
تفاؤليه ان شاء الله لا يعني ما يبقاش
التاثير سلبي ولكن يكون ايجابي على السفر
هو في بصراحه حاجتين يعني حاجه ايجابيه
وحاجه سلبيه الحاجه الايجابيه ان اا
شايفين نشاط ملحوظ في الطيران المدني في
اقبال كبير من شركات الطيران على شراء
طيران في عوده لانشاء شركات جديده بشكل
جديد لما بعد كورونا وهو الشركات المنخفضه
التكاليف او الطائرات المنخفضه التكاليف
همم وده يؤدي ان هيكون
بالضبط الكارترفلايس ولكن هي الجديد فيها
ان هي ما كانتش منتشره في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط والعالم العربي ولكن حاليا بنشوف
بعض الدول بتسعى ان هي تنشئ شركات وباعداد
طائرات ضخمه 70 هنا بعض الدول هتنشئ شركات
بحوالي اكثر ب 500 طياره وده رقم ضخم جدا
في عالم شرطه كمان هيخلي وتيره الطيران
اسرع وهيخلي المرونه في المواعيد والمرونه
في الاسعار هتكون اسرع لكن خلينا ناكد ان
في تحدي ثاني مهم جدا بيواجه كل شركات
الطيران القائمه او اللي هتنشا وهو الحرب
طبعا الروسيه الاوكرانيه لان اسعار الوقود
غير مستقره بالمره احنا في عام واحد 2000
اللي هو عام 2022 شفنا سعر البرميل الوقود
120$ وحاليا بيتجاوز ال 90 دولار وده سعر
بيخلي شركات الطيران دائما تبقى عندها
مشكله في السياسه السعريه التحدي الثاني
والمهم اللي ناس كثير ما بتاخذش بالها منه
هو تحدي التصنيع الخاص بقطع غيار الطائرات
نفسها لان
اولا في مشكله عندنا في الشحن المشكله
الثانيه ان في مصانع موجوده اصلا في منطقه
الحرب او منطقه النزاع
ومؤثره على تصنيع السيارات على العديد من
القطع الغيارات
تصير احسن حتى لو رجع انتعاش هذا القطاع
لغايه ما تخلص ها الحرب يعني ما ما راح
تعيشوا راح يعيشوا هذا القطاع عم بيعيشوا
العالم كله من ناحيه اقتصاديه يعني
التضخم هائل هو هو الحقيقه نعم هو الحقيقه
ان الطيران اقتصاد هش زي ما بيتقال عليه
بيتاثر باي حاجه من العوامل المحيطه دي زي
ما حضرتك اشارتي في الاول وباقي كورونا
يعني فعلا دمر صناعه الطيران حضرتك قلتيها
بلفظ يعني انسب لفظ ممكن يتقال والحرب
الحاليه هي فعلا مؤثر سلبي على هذه
الصناعه خصوصا ان يعني الحرب جايه بعد
وباء كورونا وعايز اقول لحضرتك على حاجه
مهمه بس في نفس الوقت في نظره تفاؤليه
للامر لان حياه نفسها في 2020 كان
توقعاتها هنتعاف الطيران لن يكون قبل 2025
او 26 حاليا بنتكلم من 2320
وفي في شيء اخر ايجابي كان في خبر اليوم
بيتحدث عن انه همم يعني مرتبات الطيارين
ارتفعت بشكل هائل ف- على الاقل الطيارين
راح يكونوا سعيدين ومبسوطين خلال 2023 ههه
شكرا شكرا
اذا انا عايز اقول لحضرتك حاجه اكتر كمان
ان الطيارات بقت يعني الاقبال على الطلب
للطيارين بقوا اكثر كمان وتحولنا من من
زياده في الطيارين الى عجز في الطيارين
مره اخرى 2019
جزيلا لك من القاهره الكابتن محمود القطه
الطيار وخبير السلام على الجويه شكرا